je pense que j'avais de la capm et c'est
pourquoi ça c'est pas à moi ni à vous
décider si le gouvernement pense que je
nuis je vais quitter
c'était le 31 mars dernier monsieur fait
des bonnes qui répondait aux questions
des journalistes à québec si je ça que
je nuis je vais quitter il est avec nous
car presque est bonne bonsoir est ce que
vous considérez aujourd'hui que là vous
nuisez et que vous allez quitter je
parle
votre post est déjà fait mais quitter
même la politique non à ce moment si je
vais rester député de terrebonne j'étais
élu par quinze mille citoyens je pense
mais que je suis et ce mandat et quand
vous avez dit j'ai quitté ma pas
d'accords consensuels avec monsieur
leubou gérer des zecs ne l'a pas la
quatrième ne va pas là comme ça va être
sec sur le même sujet quelques pages
j'ai réalisé que j'étais peut-être pour
nuire au gouvernement en lui je suis
dingue ou induire des collègues j'ai
trop de respect pour ce qui est faible
pas le goût de mettre les enfants alors
je pense que c'est la bonne décision
pour tout le monde où l on va revenir au
fond mais est-ce que je dois comprendre
que vous nous dites clairement je vais
terminer mon mandat j'ai été élu par la
population mais je ne vais pas me
représenter
non je dis pas ça parce que j'ai
toujours dit que le travail que j'ai
occupé depuis trois ans et pour mieux le
travail les plus motivants g8
électivement depuis depuis je travaille
maintenant dans le cadre dans lequel les
fonds souhaite exercer bon méchant dit
citer que ces terres étaient pas
conformes aux règles moi je ne peux non
plus mais posé je produis à la banque
ces jours ci selon le câble intérêt à
travailler ou encore des situations pour
l'instant je pense que je disais
d'entrée de jeu vous avez perdu ce
combat là contre la commissaire à
l'éthique
elle avait été clair dans ses autres
rapports vous deviez vendre vous n'avez
pas vendu est-ce que c'est monsieur
legault a dit il allait perdre un
million $ s'ils vendaient ce que c'est
ça la raison vous alliez perdre un
million si vous vendez vos
participations c'est plus complexe que
ça il faut se rappeler aussi j'avais
treize classement entreprises privées qu
un choix humain poste mais vendus
nous une haine qui est à l'utilisation
présente moi qui ai pas un hors-jeu
ouest à rester une entreprise pour
lequel depuis après un an et demi j'ai
demandé à ces actions de voir certains
acheteurs faut comprendre c'est une
petite entreprise qui est à la recherche
de qualité aux soins de base constante
aux entreprises en recherche d'argent
ben il avait ça dans l'entreprise c'est
seulement que un point d'inflexion et
que les investisseurs ont plus d'argent
disponible que la combine a besoin
d'avoir des marchés secondaires donc
cette compil il opte présentement notre
marché secondaire dont il veut tout
d'abord un enjeu de taille
ça fait déjà quand même même si monaco
je voudrais poser est ce qu on comprend
que vous auriez quand même pu obliger
l'a obligé obligé jarrier +20 mais j'ai
rien perdu de l'argent beaucoup c'est
une question de contexte
je dois avouer que ce classement là qui
est problématique
d'autres raisons quand même une portion
relativement important de mon patrimoine
d'argent j'ai gagné en à la politique on
se laisse écouter sur la politique c'est
parfait j'ai fait ça un petit
connaissance de cause ne se guérit
l'argent qui j'ai pu gagner la soie de
mon france que pour une expression de la
valeur pour son aval à monsieur le
ministre vous venez pas perdre un
million de patrimoine vivant
je pense que non il y avait par contre
je le vends existants
les dirigeants d'entreprises de ça avec
son prêt à m'aider avant katrina
alors c'est toujours un marché qui
m'intéressent les quarts ou bonnes
conditions est-ce que céréales et
pouvoir vendre et revenir parce que si
vous vous rendez vous pourriez revenir
mines s est revenu au ministre mouss est
réaliste vincent ce que oui mois de
contrôles aux ports le marché parce que
encore une fois des sociétés de petite
capitalisation privée et un point
d'inflexion omonia on a vu un engouement
récemment sur les croquis technologie
ccd currencies si c'est le point
d'inflexion où il ya plus de d'argent
disponible que d'argent qui est requis
par l'entreprise n'y avait pas les
sections où il ya marché secondaire de
production encore ça peut arriver dans
un mois
donc c'est passé bon depuis deux ans
cela dit monsieur fils gabin vous êtes
en contravention du code d'éthique qui
dit à l'article 46 fille malade mignolet
vous le répéter quarante fois dans tous
les rapports qui dit vous n'avez pas le
droit d'avoir des départs dans une
entreprise privée qui fait des marchés
qui fait des affaires avec le
gouvernement
donc depuis deux ans vous savez vous
êtes en contravention avec le code dit
étonné témoin devoir être marre je
respecte l'opinion de la commissaire à
l'éthique dans le pré choix mais
permettez-moi d'animaux une opinion sur
ce aussi parce que la tête 46 en
question fait référence comme ou liées
au marché des clés top donc une belle
vision à trois marchés avec l'état elle
paye c'est qu'on dit d'électricité chez
hydro québec
elle fait son rapport d'impôt et elles
remboursent un prêt qui avait été
octroyé en 2016 2017 alors qu'on s'est
quand même je ne vous le dis je pense
très clairement conscience de 3.13 il
n'y a eu aucune malversation
il n'y a eu aucun conflit d'intérêts ça
c'est le contexte maintenant la
commissaire de curgies mais elle
pourrait le payer et du québec ou
offerts par des poules ce marché vtt ou
avoir un prêt alors juste se sont vus
mais moi je vais vous dire que comme
ministre de l'économie jusqu'à ce matin
j'ai jamais lu aucune situation dans
laquelle je réponds oui mais c'est pas
vous étiez un conflit a dit que le
simple fait d'avoir qu elle prétend puis
elle dit qu'il ya un marché il ya un
lien autrement dit en cette entreprise
l'état québécois par investissement
québec par l'autre etc et que est juste
ça ça vous met en conflit avec le code
d'éthique exacte doit effectivement les
exactions et et la députée revenus
députés elle vous demande passer à 10 6
choisissent à faux vous mettiez ça dans
une fiducie sans droit de regard
est ce que vous allez faire ça tout de
même se change les idées les actions des
biens option quand même je les donnerai
où je les garde
il prépare et signe
qui dans leur programme non parce que
monsieur lebon a dit ça va être
difficile pour lui de le faire parce que
s'il veut vendre c'est sans droit de
regard
comment il va faire va se retrouver dans
l'impossibilité de vendre d'acheter il
faut comprendre une mare ou de fusion de
deux regards tout ce que je sais c'est
que on a des titres actions qui sont
protégés par un ancien ce parti ait pas
de transactions de l'intérieur de ces
temps sombres de vaud de merrill llp
pourquoi ici c'est bon d'une part je ne
suis jugé pas eu de malversation n'y a
pas eu de conflit mais deuxièmement
depuis deux ans les recettes comme les
autres sites que j'ai vendu je n'ai
vendu 11 était déjà scellée c'est ce
qu'ont comprenez on va terminer avec la
lazio se fait qu'on comprenait c'est que
monsieur legault vous et d'autres vous
êtes les règles du jeu doivent changer
ça doit être un peu plus haut pour les
gens qui ont de l'argent qui valait à
lui faire de la politique
les règles mais vous comprenez la
réponse qu on vous faisait que beaucoup
de gens me faisais c'est à dire on peut
pas changer les règles du jeu en pleine
partie
entièrement d'accord avec vous
d'ailleurs je pense que vous dégustez
j'ai passé huit heures sur le conseil
d'administration
la caisse de dépôt j'étais la bonne
maîtrise des coûts payés public plus
jamais été en situation confiait
pourquoi et des règles qui existent je
pense que dans un autre n'en vaut une
autre législature je pense que ça
mériterait de devoir c'est de l'or parce
que ce qui est important
le froid c'est qu'il faut croire que les
ministres dans une situation d'avoir des
conflits le sort peut faire de
différentes façons je pense que les
règles et compte présentement je suis je
suis pudeur dont je peux le dire
cd la glotte époque là faut juste
ajuster mais sur sa rente quelqu'un ça
devrait changer parce que ça va être
compliqué au niveau des oppositions mais
le fait d'avoir des relais comme ça
c'est clair c'est plus un peu plus
ironique mais là comme c'est
malheureusement un move on apprend des
10150 pas je pense qu'ils demandaient de
revoir
une personne à personne alors je dois
vous laisser aller monsieur ferry bonne
merci d'avoir parlé en direct s'est
apprécié merci on va suivre ça merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit